yes first here's the thing now that I'm
in charge get on my coattails you can't
be messing around at the office I look
at it this way
promotion car white we're gonna change
things over around the office I'm gonna
let Alice know who's in charge now let's
keep things as Sam oh my god what is
this that's what we call diversify you
even know get used to this
[Music]
[Applause]
gave itself
give it feel like I should
[Music]
keeping a living
bless them they're gonna be a factor in
this year's Tour de Francia we all
believe in you there we go oh you lost
his helmet he missed the Flamingo Oh
what is it that's not beer no it's
whiskey i watered it down though okay
all right fine
with beer here we go come on come on
there's ol hasselhoff baywatch those
beers you're doing great no dude I can't
do I'm starting to get hot mouth oh come
on they need your house taken Bob like a
while
[Music]
[Applause]
you sleep
[Music]
keep coming in my daughter
did you come for
it's awesome it's good a dream of mine
since I heard about it in the penthouse
letters my grandma used to read them to
me so I can fall asleep more easily
[Music]
[Applause]
you